hey 42 here ah the koala bear such
adorable little balls of fluffy
stupidity don't let it suave looks and
longing beady eyes fill you into
thinking that it's up to something there
really is absolutely nothing going on in
there scientists have discovered that
the beloved koala bear may be the least
intelligent mammal on the planet don't
believe me look this one's trying to
climb a bloody painting oh you guys saw
that did you they may have large fluffy
heads but a koala brain is tiny making
up just 2% of its body weight the
smallest brain to body size ratio of any
mammal they also have a smooth brain
which is evolutionary language for
they're about a million years late to
the party
koalas are so stupid that if you take a
few eucalyptus leaves that they love and
put them on a plate in front of them
it won't eat them because it thinks that
if it's not attached to a tree then it
can't possibly be food but not only are
they stupid koala bears generally just
make terrible animals they're just put
together all wrong their favorite food
is so inadequate that they have to move
really slowly to preserve energy
eucalyptus leaves are ridiculously low
in nutrients and calories they need to
eat 2,000 leaves a day to survive it's
like us humans living entirely off
celery
okay your friend it work may have tried
that diet for a month but eventually
it's gonna end badly
eucalyptus truly is a terrible food it's
not even food eucalyptus leaves do
everything they can to make it perfectly
clear that they don't want to be eaten
not only are they practically inedible
they're chuyia and tougher than your
grandma's pork chops but they are also
poisonous but koalas we were like listen
boys we've got this and dedicated their
entire evolutionary history to adapting
themselves to be able to digest this
toxic plant I'm not dying afterwards
when they could have eaten literally any
other food and done considerably better
being animals they get so little energy
in fact that they need to sleep 18 hours
a day but they're too darn
intellectually deficient to find another
food to eat eucalyptus is so difficult
to digest that it takes four whole days
and only adult koalas have sufficiently
developed digestive systems to cope with
it baby koalas ah can't digest the
leaves at all in fact they their own
mother's feces yeah it's known as fecal
pop and they need it to survive not only
that but they use their claws to scrape
the poop dinner out of their mother's
anus koalas may look dosel but get on
the wrong side of these moronic poop
eating fur balls and you'll regret it in
fact they go full psycho yet despite
their occasional hissy fits the koala
bear has been named by one animal
conservationist as the most boring of
all animals poor little guys and if
after all that you still need more proof
that koalas really are the most pathetic
and unfortunate animal about 90% of all
koalas have chlamydia which makes them
incontinent so they spend all day
pissing themselves and if you fought
this cuddly little misfit couldn't get
any weirder this is what they sound like
yeah thanks for watching this tower of
testosterone is Danish man-beast Peter
Freudian he is the most interesting man
in the world each part of the tree wants
to kill you in a different organizing
way the fruits it grows look like apples
smell like apples and even taste like
apples put her nuts apples